في ضواحي اوديس يتدرب هؤلاء الجنود
الاوكرانيين على اسقاط طائرات مسيره من
طراز شاهد طائرات انتحاريه ايرانيه الصنع
يبلغ مداها حوالي 2500 كيل متر هي جزء من
الترسنه التي تستخدمها القوات الروسيه
لقصف الاراضي
الاوكرانيه طائره العدو المسيره من طراز
الشاهد تطير في مسار واحد العدو يحدد
الهدف يطلق مجموعه من خمس الى ع طائرات في
وقت واحد
اكد الجيش الروسي سقوط 500 طائره مسيره
وصاروخ على اهداف اوكرانيه خلال خمسه ايام
فقط مع خسائر بشريه فادحه عشرات القتلى في
منطقه كيف وخار كيف ولكن ايضا في كروب
نفسكي وسط البلاد من جانبه نجح الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني في تحييد طائرات مسيره
وصواريخ الرئيس فلمير زيلينسكي وعد
بالحفاظ على هذه
الوتيره يبذل الممثلون الاوكراني في
الخارج كل ما في وسعهم لضمان تسليم انظمه
وصواريخ دفاع جوي اضافيه انها الاولويه
رقم
واحد يواصل الاوكرانيين قصفهم لمدينه
بجرود الحدوديه الروسيه وذلك بعد تحقيق
ضربه غير مسبوقه يوم السبت الماضي والتي
قتل فيها 25 شخصا على الخطوط الاماميه
يكافح المتحاربون من الجانبين من اجل
تحقيق مكاسب بعد عامين من حرب داميه l